the clothes in your closet may
contribute to pollution in the ocean
more than 80% of marine pollution comes
from human activities on land scientists
have found that fibers like those in
synthetic clothing are contaminating
aquatic life then tracy shows us how one
company is working to fix that problem
there in everything from yoga pants to
running shorts to that soft fuzzy fleece
tiny shreds of plastic that shed in the
wash and can be eaten by the same marine
life we eat unlike dryers most washing
machines don't have filters that trap
lint so when you throw synthetic
garments in the wash material breaks off
and can slip past sewage treatment
plants and into waterways the so called
micro fibers have turned up in waters
across the globe including Lake Michigan
and along the shores of the Gulf of
Mexico when we see reports showing
microfiber in in the ocean and fish in
plankton you know we're alarmed by its
impact Doug Freeman is chief operating
officer of Patagonia which is trying to
find a solution the company known for
its outdoor apparel such as fleece
jackets funded a study on microfibers
last year by the University of
California Santa Barbara researchers
there found that a single synthetic
fleece jacket released as much as
250,000 micro fibers when washed in a
machine newer higher quality garments
shed less than older ones even in a
wastewater treatment plant that's
filtering up to 95% there's still a
really high number that are getting
through project research her best ruff
says underwater creatures can ingest the
material for fish a lot of times the
micro fibers are found in their
intestines and most the times we're not
eating that part so direct ingestion
with fish isn't as much of a concern but
with shellfish they're actually getting
embedded in the tissue and that's the
part that we eat if you're aware this is
a significant problem and that you're
contributing to it why not just stop
selling these items because in many
cases these items have longer useful
life than their biodegradable
counterparts ultimately
we come down to choices you know do we
want something that has that micro fiber
impact or do we want something that's
more throw away Patagonia has not yet
changed how it designs its fleece but
the company is working to find new
fabrics that shed less it also wants its
customers to buy only the clothes they
actually need and wash them less we
encourage customers to wash it just as
few times as they possibly can you don't
need to wash it with every year spot
cleaning is really important for CBS
this morning Ben Tracy Los Angeles Bravo
to Doug Freeman and Patagonia for even
noticing a new socket
I guess I'm never gonna wash my fleece
again you know I'll keep wearing it I've
never washed at the lint brush